are you I'm good it's good to see you my
bro nice to see what great t-shirt as
well
you can't go wrong throw yeah nice work
yeah you can't I expect high standards
if this kind of thing from you I'm glad
I'm glad I made the cut I mean I'm glad
you know what I mean let me start by
saying I love the movie it's so good I
would imagine when you get in let's talk
about your character for a second I
would imagine you're reading it on the
script and they're describing it but you
there's oh there has to be a lot of
imagination as to what this thing's
gonna finally look like what what was it
like the first time you see the finished
film because the visual effects are
crazy dude yesterday was the first time
I saw it at the premiere it was a trip
it was amazing
you know especially watching in Dolby
IMAX and all of that with the 3d glasses
it was like it was phenomenal what we're
talking about here is like the forefront
of science and technology blurred with
you know hopefully a deep you know an
emotionally honest narrative you know
that's what Robert does so well blur in
the - but yeah it was amazing to watch
you you know every movie you do is is is
like that somewhat you know even if
we're doing a little art house movie you
know I'm there in the scene you know
we're playing out this scene you don't
know how it's going to look how they're
going to score it how they're going to
cut it you know this is a kind of more
explicit version of that unknown but
it's always unknown you know this always
is always the unknown so it's always a
trip to see it I I the look of your
character is you're one of the few that
there's a lot of machine just talk a
little bit about the look of your
character and what maybe you responded
or what you've loved about it hmm
I just think this idea that you've got a
cyborg this like really vein you know as
this face put on top human face put on
top of his his his metal buddy and such
and there's spent all of his money on a
decorated you know what I just think
that was just such it so appealing is so
such a
delicious roll you know delicious
proposition you know to take on when I
Skyped with Robert the first time I was
doing a movie I was at in Belgrade and
he was like dude your character is the
most badass looking character in the
movie and I was like the most badass man
on the planet is telling me that I'm
gonna be badass I was just like this is
just the coolest thing ever
you know Robert Rodriguez man my hero
and um and he was true to his word one
of the things about this is that I'm not
the biggest fan of 3d but then three
reason this is exceptional me to talk a
little bit about how you filmed it
because I believe it was all filmed in
3d yeah and the fact that you should see
this in 3d 100% I am NOT a fan of 3d I
got half way through yesterday I was
like oh my god I don't have a headache
well you know these glasses on her in my
head and I'm not even noticing that this
is in 3d you know I suppose technology
has just come around you know this is
what we've been waiting for you know I
always loved the idea of 3d but the
reality of it you know I think it makes
it 40% darker usually as well these
things are just you know it's not fair
on the DP or the gaffer and all that
when these these kind of conversions are
happening but this this is it's
phenomenal you know and I think there's
1500 CGI shots in this movie you know
it's a smorgasbord of beautiful amazing
steaks that just takes you on a visual
rollercoaster talk a little bit about I
one of the things I also respond to with
this movie is just the world in a whole
world and it feels like it's lived in
and there's these practical sets with
these massive establishing shots you
talk a little bit about the world and
maybe what you you know responded to her
dug about it I responded to the fact is
so more we call true you know I love
this notion well I don't love I love the
fact that is so colorful it represents
you know my community back in London
more than I see on screen you know to
have every color under the
coexisting together it's kind of sad and
and reflective of real life that you
know these are the shunted people the
Forgotten people the the the have-nots
you know with this great economic
disparity of the two levels you know and
how and obviously that's very relevant
to the uneven distribution of wealth
that we have in America Britain and all
over the world but to go back to like
the experience of being now unset like
it was amazing to have such a physical
set you know I didn't feel like I was
making some big CGI movie while I was
doing it I was acting opposite real
people looking in their eyes the you
know the set was physical there was all
the human extras and such I didn't do
one shot on blue screen so in that way
Robert was able to focus on the emotion
and focus on a narrative and not just
get lost in in the scope of it you know
and the waiter just enhanced that
digitally afterwards and and hopefully
what we've done is made something this a
marvel to look at but he's also
emotionally rooted 100% before I run out
of time I totally have to ask you I
believe you got to work with Roland
Emmerich yeah man right what the hell
was that like yeah I'm going to see him
today he's like he's the king of making
these epic summer big movie you know
what I mean yeah he's like he's done a
few yeah I mean you learned something
from every director that you work with
and and like I learned a lot from from
Roland I just I saw a short film last
year that I wrote and is the first thing
I directed and this is a something I
enjoyed incredibly and now I begin to
watch these filmmakers from a different
point of view and to see the how a
shirred he is to see how focus is on the
tiniest little things you know he's got
these 270 extras big crane shots all
this epic stuff and then he'll come in
and just move one glass and go just go
again
and you know he's just got such an
attention an eye for detail
you know and he truly knows the epic
he's a master of the epic well talk a
little kits admit you doing the Midway
who do you play in that what's a film
about the film is about the the Battle
of Midway which is the a very decisive
battle in American naval history
therefore American military history and
therefore World War two the the way that
World War two panned out so and I play a
dive bomber it was yeah it was an
amazing experience and you know the
thing I love about these jobs is I get
to explore and go into other worlds so a
certain points like when something like
Deadpool comes along it's like not
another world for me I've lived in that
world since I was a kid the world of
comics and all of this a world like this
is something I've known I haven't you
know in our schools we might talk about
the Battle of Midway you know even the
American approach to nationalism and
military you know the the pride and
feelings towards the military here are
different from British you know
sensibilities towards a militant
military and whatnot so to go over to
Hawaii to be in Pearl Harbor to shoot in
Pearl Harbor with military personnel to
spend time with historians and and you
know Marines and offices and and and to
speak to Navy Navy wives you know spend
time with the children it was an
immersive and truly educational
experience you know to read all these
biographies about all of these these
real heroes you know it just serves to
make you feel like even more of a little
wimp modern little millennial wimp which
is coincidentally the same way that I
feel after seeing how amazingly cool my
body my metal body and that looks you
know you come out and you're like yeah
but no I'm excited I'm seeing Roland
this evening you know I know I know and
I look forward to seeing our Midway
turns out
you